Now, your character is this amazing fan
of these shortbread biscuits on "Ted Lasso."
And so when I heard that
you were gonna teach us a dessert,
I immediately transported myself
to the biscuit journey in the show.
And I thought, "Really?
"You're gonna teach us a dessert?
"How perfect."
Well, I thought I would show you something
that I was shocked you guys don't already know about.
And that is the absolutely delicious,
very naughty and very moreish Eton mess.
Well, I love naughty.
I mean...
(audience laughs)
Honestly, and this, could you not just stick
your whole face in it?
Get in there, hands in.
Smooshed.
Meringue all smashed up to bits.
Chocolate meringue.
Yeah, you could even put it in a bag,
and smack it against a wall
and get all your frustration out.
But look at how this beautiful set up.
Look at it, look at it.
I mean, look at that already.
I'd stick my head in that already.
I mean, I'm gonna stick my head in it.
Stick it all in there.
And then, usually,
I would just put like,
the red berries,
basically, whatever you have in terms of berries,
would be gorgeous in it.
A raspberry, a strawberry.
Yeah, raspberries, strawberries, yep.
Even blueberries, blueberries are yummy with it.
Blackberries.
Got blueberries here.
Yeah, blackberries.
Blackberries I don't like so much
because they're a little bit tart.
They are tart. Oh.
(audience laughs)
Look at that already.
Look at that.
But so here we have...
It's like fluff.
Macerated berries.
Whoo.
Look, it's just got orange, orange,
and lemon, and sugar,
and you just leave it to just
do it's thing.
Marinate in its juices.
For like half an hour.
And then we're gonna stick this...
I mean, it's just...
I can really taste the orange juice too.
Aww.
It's so perfect.
Have a cheeky mouthful.
Yeah, exactly, right?
(audience laughs)
Ooh.
I need this like, thank you, exactly.
Actually, that is a big gob spoon.
(audience laughs)
That is a very civilized size spoon.
(audience laughs and cheers)
I feel like this is just honest.
I would love to have that.
Mmm.
The whole bowl.
This spoon is just me being myself.
(audience laughs)
Oh, seriously.
That is the greatest spoon.
I'd totally steal that.
It really is.
Right, so,
oh, you're still here.
(audience laughs)
So we stick some of that in there.
I'm gonna put that that side.
So take a little bit.
We're gonna try and look like we're...
Just use this bit.
And stick a little bit of that...
By the way, these are beautiful. I love these.
They are so pretty.
A nice, wide stem.
They need a gentle loving re-home.
And then
let's take a little bit of that by itself.
Oh, a little bit of a...
(audience laughs)
Oh yeah.
Mouthful.
Just to check it tastes nice on route.
Oh my God.
I'm gonna create a little divot, yeah.
So a little bit of that, like a little bit
of a layer there.
Oh, God, it's so good, it's ridiculous.
(audience laughs)
Where have you been all my life?
Look, look at that.
Oooh!
(audience laughs)
Look, Drew!
I'm not kidding.
I just want you to know that like,
everyone on this show
is literally like, "Oh my God, there's two of them."
(audience and Hannah laugh)
Literally.
I think you and I were like,
separated at birth.
I know, I have to say,
when they said go on Drew,
I was like, first of all, I was like,
"Drew Barrymore!"
First.
Couldn't get over myself, living legend that you are.
I feel so less alone in the world right now,
having met you.
I do!
I really do!
Look.
Look, and then check this bit out.
Get a bit of the juicy dribble.
Mmm, juicy dribble.
Hash tag juicy dribble.
(audience cheers)
Ooh!
And then stick your face in the rest of the bit
that's in the bowl.
(audience laughs and cheers)
Isn't that just the best way to spend an afternoon?
Oh my God, it's so good.
My goodness, well...
Please, let this be the first of many hangs and visits.
Absolutely.
And as they say in "Casablanca,"
the beginning of a beautiful friendship.
Oh my God!
(audience cheers)
You've made my day!
You have too, you've made mine.
Aww!
And we can shame bell, we can dessert make,
we can laugh, we can talk about work
and motherhood and life and all of it.
The guilt of working mothers.
Oh my God, shame, shame city.
Absolutely!
It's like, you have a kid
and you literally buy a house in this new town
called Guilt City.
Yep, you do.
And you live there for the rest of your life.
And I was gonna say,
I'm just trying to be fancy in finishing off our little,
you know.
A garnish always sells it.
I mean, it always sells it,
but it's not gonna be there for long.
There we go.
(upbeat music)